You
killed killed to fight.
Is Is that the same word? Is that the
same word? You said it means No. Is that
the same word? Is that what you said? Is
that the same word? No, because you're
Thank
you.
It's
God. It's God.
The Quran wrote the Quran. It was
revealed by God to the messenger. So
then people after the messenger wrote it
down in two words. So messenger wrote it
down. Yeah. No, not the messenger.
People after so my question who wrote
the give me one word. The words were
said by God. Sure. Sure. I understand
that. And they were memorized by the
messenger. Sure. After the messenger
sign, they were written down by the
scholars. After I have a question that
give me a name for whom you wrote down.
Uh brother uh Usman. Scholar Usman.
Usman. Yesman. He was the one who
started it I believe and it was he
gathered people who had memorized the
Quran and they had all wrote it down.
Gathered the
peopleman was the king. He was yes it
was Sahaba but that he did not wrote
down he collected. He he he collected
the people who memorized Quran. The
people who memorized who that I'm asking
name there's hundreds. There was mult so
many. Why does it matter if I don't
know? I'm sure I can find it. Why does
it matter if I don't know the exact
name? There was hundreds that they could
memorize. Well, they the reason why we
would say they probably didn't memorize
it is because they had to go and they
had to go collect manuscripts and copy.
They didn't collect manuscripts. They
already memorized it. It was all by
memory. They came together and they
wrote the first manuscript together.
That was the purpose of King. Listen,
this is this is Sai Bukari, right? And
Sai Bukari when Cuz you're you kind of
um we're talking about how they
collected the Quran, right? You're
talking about when they when they first
they just collected the people who the
memorizers, the ones who memorized. They
didn't. They had to No, because we
learned this as children. Okay. So, I'm
going to show you how deep these
hopefully my um my connection is good.
But look, so if we go to um Sai Bukari,
let's go to
um you're familiar with uh are do you
know the story of how they had the other
Quran manuscripts burned when they
rewrote a copy of the Quran? No. No.
Well, okay. Let me try to show you this,
brother. No, that's not it. Hey, I'm
curious. Which religion are you? We're
Christians, brother. You guys are
Christians? Yeah. So, you have clear
answers to all of these questions then?
100%. When someone tells you who wrote
the Bible. Yeah, we do. What is Who
wrote the Bible?
Yeah, we got we got prophets who wrote
it and the companions of Jesus wrote it.
Matthew, Mark, Luke, John, Paul. So,
you're here preaching. Why aren't you
responding? You're here to preach,
right? You're here for people to come
and approach you and ask questions. I'm
I'm here. I'm here. I'm here. He's
looking He's searching some information.
I I could talk to you and look at this
for at the same time. The Bible, is it
different than what what I told you?
Yes. Yes, of course. Tell me. It's
different. So like we we have the names
of the people who wrote who wrote the
Bible. You guys don't really have the
names of those who wrote the Quran. You
might have some ideas of scribes and
stuff, but the story that you have that
you have in in your mind is kind of
mixed up. You know, the story of of Uma
collecting the Quran and rewriting it.
Why is that mixed up? Because so the the
story is not about them writing the
original one, right? It's it's so
basically there was already a manuscript
out there. Do you know do you know who
Hopsa is? Ha. No. She was um so you had
Abu Bakr who was the first Caleb, right?
And then you had Umar was the second.
Yes. Hafsa was Umar's daughter. Okay.
His daughter. Yeah. So first Abu Bakr
had the Quran collected and put into
one. There was no Quran collected. Yes.
Okay. Brother. Brother. I studied this
from very young age. You Christian. Why
you know more than you don't know more?
Because I studied this. It's okay. Like
we we could both learn from each other.
Uh no but you're telling me something
untrue. Okay. was never ever formally
collected in topic. Yes, there it is.
4986 was never formally collected in one
copy until the time of Yeah. Go to page.
What's What's the What's the one where
it was they were burned? What's which
which one is that one? 4987, right?
Oh, but no, this is the one where they
were burned. Cuz that's the one I'm
looking
for cuz I my my connection is a little
too slow. Hold on. I got it. Who
copies the burnt? So, who was the Bible
revealed to? Oh, the Bible. Oh, here it
is. I got it right here. I knew I was
right. 4987. So, the SU card 4987. And
And like you said, we we'll we'll answer
the opposite, too, cuz it's fair to ask
this. Okay. It's kind of long, but it's
worth reading. Okay. So, card 4987
narrated and come on. Like I told you,
come on. It's so There was nothing
before. No, there was. I'm telling you.
It's telling you right here. No, this is
talking about a different This is It's
telling you right here. This is Every
Muslim knows this. Let me let me show
you. I'm going to show you what I'm
talking about. Okay. So, Hudifa bin Ali
came to Uman at the time when the people
of Sham and the people of Iraq were
waging war to conquer Armenia. And I
don't know how to say that word, but
Hudifa was afraid of their people.
Shamanak differences in the recitation
of the Quran. So he said to Uman, "Oh
chief of the believers, save this nation
before they defer about the book as the
Jews and the Christians did before." So
there are differences among people how
people here. He's saying how in the
Bible and the Torah it was changed by
mankind. That's not what he's saying.
He's saying he's not saying that the
Bible's changed but that Jews and
Christians argue over it because they
have different look different. You're
misunderstanding. You see this is the
issue here. You are misunderstanding
what it is saying afraid of their
differences in the recitation. What is
differences of recitation of the Quran?
Differences. This is referring back to
the Bible and to the Torah and how they
different recitation. They changed the
books. Okay. So, does this mean that
talking about how they changed the Bible
and the Torah? So, does this mean that
they changed the Quran says there's
differences in recitation? It's saying
right here. It's saying right here. Stop
changed it before the people change
their before the people have their
influence over the books just like they
have in the last. Look, it says um Hudo
was afraid of their Shem and Iraq
differences in the recitation of the
Quran. So, they had differences of
recitation in the Quran. They're scared
that they're going to change it. But
there are already differences. He's
saying differences in recision of the
Quran. Finished the course. So he said
before No, no. Before where where the
Yes. So he said to him, "Save this
nation before about the book as the Jews
and the Christians did before. It didn't
happen yet." He's saying save it as they
did before. But there's already
differences just like with the Jews and
Christians. It's saying as they did
before talking about the past, right? So
let's keep reading. We're You can't move
on from this. Why? We We're going to
agree. We need to establish it. We
can't. I'm not here to agree and
disagree because you're spreading and I
think from my perspective I grew up
learning this. Yes. Me and multiple
other Muslim. Do you have you must have
this conversation a lot? Yes, I do. You
show them this and they tell you. No,
they know they know what this means.
There differences between Jews and what
he's saying. Yes, there's different Jews
and the Christians. They change the
Bible. That's why the Bible has modules,
brother. This doesn't say that. What it
says is is that before the Jew, they
differ about the book. Not that the book
is different or changed, but they differ
about the book. Right? Listen, language
can be a bit tricky here. It's not
tricky. Tricky brother completely
different interpreted
differences in the recitation. This
doesn't mean like you're thinking, oh,
differences in recitation. Oh, they're
all saying different [__] They are.
That's literally what that means.
Incorrect. Differences recent is being
used as a way to say differences in
interpret change. No, not
interpretation. Okay. So, then there's
Quran's chang. He's saying if you read
right after it says save them as they
did before. All right. So let me let me
I got you. So let me let me grant you
this. Okay. If I grant you this
position, I'm going to show you how this
doesn't help with the rest of the So we
agree. We don't agree. I'm I'm granting
it to you though for for the sake of
argument. So cuz I want to show you the
main point. I have to go study. Wait
wait wait. Let me show you this. I just
want you to understand something right
as they do before. I can't move as they
do before. But I want to show you that
he talking to you about before. I hear
you. Trust me. I'm not being stubborn. I
hear what you're saying. Okay. All
right. I just wanted to show you the
main point of the hadith. All right.
Continue. Okay. So, look. Okay. So, um
so um so Uman in response to all that,
right? So, um man sent a message to
Hapsa saying, "Send us the manuscripts
of the Quran so that we may compile the
Quranic material. Oops, sorry. So that
we may compile the Quranic materials in
perfect copies and return the
manuscripts to you." So, they collected
the manuscripts of the Quran. Yes. Yes.
Yes.
Yes. Uh who is this in the time of This
is in the time of Uman where they
already brought the
memorizers. Yes. This had already
happened. It says manuscripts. Yes.
Manuscript. So not memorizers. Why were
there manuscripts? Because they
collected the Quran. They were
manuscripts because the memorizers had
already done their part. This was as
soon as Osman came. That's why this is
in the time of speak a little slowly
here. was already he was already and
when came in you're missing the point.
Okay, I'll hear you. When Osman already
came in he as I said first thing he
asked me fam who wrote I told him Osman
collected the memorizers and they wrote
down these manuscripts. Why are there
manuscripts before Usman? There is no
this is during Osman's time. Okay. So
then why so why doesn't man have the
manuscripts already? Why does he have to
ask somebody else? There is multiple
manuscripts. You think he has every
Yeah. Why doesn't he have them?
Why are they with every single
manuscript? Why would he have every
single manuscript? My question is why
are they with Hafsa? Why are they with
him? Why not? Why would they not be? Why
would they all be with him? Wait, I'm
asking if you know why. Do you know the
story behind that? Because m there's
manuscripts. They're out for multiple.
Yeah, but why are they with Havsa? No
one wants She bought a manuscript. She
got the manuscript. Everyone has Then
why do they make these manuscripts so
that people can have the word and read?
The people the people didn't have look
listen watch this no one but her had it.
No look look watch. Umah so Uman sent a
message to Hapsa not everybody else but
to Hafsa specifically. Send us the
manuscripts of the Quran so that we may
compile the Quranic materials in perfect
copies and return the manuscripts to
you. So she has the manuscript. She had
the manuscript. I have all of the
manuscripts. So why why are you assuming
that this lady has all of the
manuscripts in the Quran? That is
ridiculous. What I'm saying? One lady,
she has all the manuscripts. Why doesn't
um man have the manuscripts? Why does he
have any? He probably doesn't have all
of them. Maybe he doesn't have all of
them. So what does he need hers for? If
he has memorizers who can just rewrite
the Quran or make another copy if they
all memorize it. Maybe he didn't have
cuz this was in the beginning, right?
Where they had Yiani. This was in the
beginning where he brought the
memorizers. You're still stuck on the
memorizers. That was just where they
wrote down the manuscripts. my my
manuscripts were written. They're the
same. I hear you. It tells her, "Hey,
send me all of them so we can make a
perfect copy. Make sure nothing. Listen,
listen to this point. Listen to this
point cuz I'm I'm with you, but just
listen to the point." Okay? If they if
they had memorizers who did their job
and wrote the manuscripts, right? Why
would Uman if he also had memorizers and
memorized the Quran himself and had
memorizers with him, why would he need
to go somewhere else? Why are you so
that he had every memorizer with him,
every manuscription? Maybe he wants to
complete certain cuz when you're going
through so they didn't all memorize the
Quran. There's plenty of memorizers. Is
he one of them? I I don't know to be
honest on that memoriz but it it
wouldn't make sense if he was for him to
be asking help to to make a copy of the
Quran. Right. Okay. But there's already
Okay. What's What's your point here?
Your point is that there is different
copies. There's different copies out
there. Yes, there's different copies.
I'm going to tell you why this is
incorrect. That's what it says.
Brother, what you laughing at, brother?
This guy. You guys misinterpreting the
entire hadith and coming up with great
I'm not we're literally just reading man
that's all we do. I told you as soon as
you came in who wrote the Quran I told
you they were memorizers they wrote it
down into memory but you didn't know who
was and you know why the only reason
your argument is even working a bit is
because you you're you're going over
what we said in the beginning about how
about how uh this was during Osman's
time and how they mentioned before we're
like oh we're going to go over this
we're going to skip by this but now you
remember I said skipped by like all
right I'll allow you and we're going to
skip by and now your argument is working
a little no no I'm saying no I was
showing look brother I was showing you
that I I was I could grant to your
position. Yes. And your position still
would it wouldn't hold once we kept
reading. Here's the entire position,
brother. Here's I know this hadith.
Okay. Do you? So, do you know that he
burned the other manuscripts?
Listen, man. First of all, your whole
argument in the beginning, you were
talking about how there was times uh
before Osman, there were no manuscripts
before, which it says right here. Cuz
this whole hadith that you spent forever
searching up, it talks about the first
word I read right there. Didn't write
it. Had nothing. He didn't write it.
Yeah. No, but he collected the
memorizers who wrote it down. He wrote
down the script. That's so I I told you
that UMA collected the Qurans and you
collect the memorizers. I said he
memorized wrote down. Okay, I got you.
Where does it say in the hadith that he
collected memorizers? I showed you that
it said this. Why are you listen? Okay,
look. I'm I'm my whole point was that
that UMA collected manuscripts of the
Quran. You said no no no. So that's what
I was showing you that he collected
manuscripts of the Quran. He collected
to ensure okay everything everything is
in order everything. Okay. So all right
so let's keep reading. Watch this. Look.
So um well we can't keep moving on.
Yeah. We have we have to stabilize
points. I'm showing you that we keep not
stabilizing. Not stabilizing. All right.
So do we agree at least that that Uman
collected manuscripts of the Quran so
that he can make a perfect copy?
Maybe it'll be around the
You know when he asked how they're
saying they're Oh,
did you read four? In the dialect of
Qur. Oh, so you read four. Yes. Oh, but
you didn't want me to read four. Come
on, man. This This is good. This is It
is good. I tried to do this. There's
meaning that I'm reading forward. Yeah.
Let me read Let me read the whole I
tried. You and me dialect of the Qur.
Okay. But you know what they're saying
when they're talking about the dialect.
If they disagree. Different. No. If they
disagree. Different languages. Bro. Does
it say if they disagree? No. The Ces is
a dialect of Arabic. It's still Arabic.
Yes. There's brother. I speak Arabic.
The slang is ridiculous. I don't
understand so many different Arabics. I
feel it. Oh my god. But there's a but
the Quran is the Quran. No, I didn't.
Bro. So So does it say there's different
dialects? I don't understand. I'm
Egyptian. Okay. When Syri Syrians talk
Arabic, I don't understand [__] I don't
know what they're saying. It's both
Arabic. I understand. So, when they're
saying remove the copies, they're
talking about different dialect so we
can have one dialect. And that's why in
the Quran, there's no Oh, there's a
Syrian Quran with this dialect. There's
an Egyptian Quran with there is there's
a Moroccan Quran with with different
Well, I wouldn't say it's different
dialects. It's different. No, it's the
same Arabic. No, like like the English,
brother. I promise you once we finish
this, I'm going to show you what we
have. And that, by the way, that is not
a correct copy of the English. No. Yeah,
forget. No, not I agree. I'm talking
about Arabic. One is the Arabic. I know.
I'm talking about Arabic. If if they do
different dialectics, perhaps it is to
help to help them. No, brother. It's
it's the same. No, brother. It's Arabic.
I promise. It's not English. In Arabic,
it has the same words as the You're said
you're Egyptian. Yep. So, you use the
Huffs, what is called the Huffs
Recitation of the Quran. In Morocco,
they use what is called the war. Okay.
There are literal word differences,
words missing and stuff. If you buy
Okay, so
99.99% of the Qurans in the world are
all the same. You're going to give me
one from Yes. Yes. You're going to get
me one from Morocco. Of course. I'm sure
there's one in Morocco and one in
[__] Algeria with with differences.
Everyone every all the Qurans are the
same. That's what makes it. So if I show
you the If I show you two and you're
going to talk I'm sure you found one,
bro. From God knows where. Dude, I have
I have a whole library. Hey man, I got I
got you a library of Bibles talking
about that. No, but I'm not making the
same claim as you. This
this any Quran you buy anywhere
99.99% not telling you you won't find
there's a bunch of [__] that you can
find something which you did and you're
using that to hold this whole argument.
What's my argument? You're telling me
that oh there's there's a different
dialect in Moroccan and I'm not saying
there's a different I'm not saying
there's a different dialect. You're
saying look it's still Arabic but the
dialect's slightly different. I'm not I
didn't say let me tell you my brother.
You're not listening to me. I listen to
you. So what I'm saying is is that this
narrative that there's only one Quran
with no differences, no differences,
100% true, that's false%. Let me tell
you why. Because I have I have multiple
Quran, not dialects, not how you
annunciate a word or pronounce it. The
text itself, the written text is
different in one Quran versus another.
That's what I'm telling you. Okay. Where
is this uh Quran from? I They're from
from Morocco, from Saudi Arabia, from
Egypt. They're all different countries.
I know dialect that's it's not okay. Can
I show you? Yeah. Okay, I'll show you.
I'mma trust you cuz you I thought y'all
would have Let me see. Man, look. So,
what does What does this What does this
say? If you can uh I don't know.
[Music]
Yeah. Explanation or statement.
And what is what is like this? I don't
know. I don't know. You don't know what
the Okay. Do you know um it's it's
huffs. [__] you should know bro. So
it like for example if you go to surah
um go to surah three s three. Go to this
one right here. This page right here. I
don't know what which what
Anthony. Yeah. Come here really quick.
There's a difference here. Is there a
difference here in the in the wash?
Which one? This one. What is this? No,
this is not the one. That's a doubt. Why
is it? Because that's a Z. Give it to D.
Okay. So, you're just okay. You're just
making another Let me show you. Let me
show you an actual one. Go. Let's Let's
do uh chapter 3. Sir Iran. Let's do Sir
Imran. We'll do uh not 157. Let's do
140. What is it? 146 or 147? Yeah.
Yes. All
right. What number is this? What is What
is that word right there? Yeah. Okay.
Andy, there it is. Yeah. This is
dialect. It's not dialect. Clearly the
word is different brother. The word is
not different. Yeah. One is one doesn't
have a same thing. This means killed. No
kill. No. One means fight. The other
means kill, right? No. Yes. This means
fight. He killed. Killed. No, it's not.
One is bro. I speak Arabic. One is one
is fought with the one is fought with
the
does not mean fought. Killed. Fight to
kill. This is they were killed.
Killed. This is dialect. This is old
dialect. Yeah. So look look this means
this means to kill, right? You're saying
this means to kill, right? No, this
means he killed already. He killed. All
right. And this says he killed. No, it's
not he killed. It's that they were
killed. No, bro. I speak Arabic. What
are you saying, dude? Pay attention.
Don't talk Arabic. Pay attention. I've
grew up. All right. Does this have the
alf that this other one doesn't? No,
there's no instead are different for the
dialect. So it changes, right? No, the
word is not changing. The me nothing has
changed. The dialect is different. This
is a different way of pron This is all
pronunciation. You know what?
Can you stay here for one second? Where
is this guy, man? Yeah, he's right here.
This This literally has a different
word. Yeah, this guy. It's Spike versus
Kill. Hold on. I'll bring him here.
This is crazy, man.
You have no idea
what you think that is. Brother, I know.
Not really.
I said not really cuz you cuz you don't
understand these words right here, bro.
Brother, you're the ones who don't
understand the word. Literally means
they were killed. He killed. It says he
killed. Oh my god. He killed. No, it's
not, bro. Okay. Look, you don't know a
lick of Arabic, my brother. I The Arabic
the Arabic speakers are going to laugh
at this. You following him? Yeah. You're
following him? Yes. So you I'm telling
you something. You don't want to follow
me. I'm telling you the truth. And the
person who gave it I'm saying is this
mean isla mean there's a fight and this
is killed does not mean fight yes it
does fight to fight to kill the other
one says they were killed bro okay do I
so if I do Google translate will that
make you yes yeah go ahead go ahead yes
killed brother come here
words. Look, look, look, look. Wow. Same
words. That's
the same words. The same words exactly.
So, what does that mean? Same word.
Kill. Okay. Where's killed? He killed.
Killed right there. Where's the kill?
Killed. Okay. The other one. Yeah. Yeah.
Do same word. I know. I I look I type in
by the Arabic. I said killed in Arabic.
This is what it brought up. Yeah. I I
know. Can you put in the other one now?
Cuz this is kutu. Can you put in? I
didn't put No, it's the same. That
That's the thing. I only said killed. I
know, but you need to put the You need
to put the different word in so that you
can see what the same word. They're You
didn't do Can you put in Put put put
that word in. It's the same. I did. It
says No, you didn't. You put You put in
killed and coutil came up, right? Put in
kato. Okay. What does that mean? Kat is
to fight. It's to fight. Okay. So, I'm
going to say to fight in Arabic. No,
brother. Put the Arabic word. You're
telling me I did I did the same in
English. I don't have Arabic language on
my phone. Not. Do you not know how to
put that word in? I don't have Arabic
language on my phone. I only have
English language. That's why I put
Google Translate. In Google Translate,
you can put in Arabic. No, but I don't
have Arabic language. You don't have
Arabic. I don't have Arabic keyboard.
Exactly. So, I just said killed in
Arabic. He's telling me a means
different word. You said to fight,
right? Contel is to fight to fight. So,
killed in Arabic is killed. Let's see.
To fight. Let's see. To fight. Two
fights in
Arabic. Oh.
Look at this different word completely.
So can you put can you can you put can
you put kala in there so that you can
see what it comes out to? I put it
through English.
You didn't put
in that's that's even different
than say katala. Okay. Say katala. It
won't it won't pick up like that. No.
But I did it through Okay. What's the
difference if I do it between English to
Arabic? Do me do do me this favor. Put
in English to Arabic. put in poor people
in Arabic or in English and and see
people. Yeah, poor people. It should be
uh msk, right? Or
no, which is another way of saying moss
is a big msk is mskin is a poor person,
right? I just I just want to hold on
hold on you got to come this way, bro.
He's not even coming up with the word
because you're like the boss of these
guys.
Okay, brother. Just stick with me for
one second. Let me stick with you for
one second. You said to fight and you
said to be
killed,
bro. Can you read Arabic? Can you read
Arabic? Okay, we don't read Arabic.
Okay. All right. So, help us out. Read
and the
camera. The perfect Arabic guy. So, it's
not a perfect honest. Yes, but I know
this word. I know this word. This word.
You don't know this word. Okay. You do
not do Okay. I don't know. Google
translate to say you didn't even do it
right. You're not even putting in the
word. Hey guys, I said in English to
fight in
Arabic. I said killed in Arabic. Look.
Wow. Just like the dude. The Arabic
speakers are going to laugh. You want to
learn something? You don't want to
learn? That's fine. Okay, brother. I'm
I'm teaching. I'm the teacher. He said
he's the teacher. You didn't even know
the word. I didn't know the word. That's
why Google Translate said exactly what I
said. It didn't even say it. Even Even
when it put fight, it gave you a
different word. It exactly. It gave me a
different word. Can you please read? No,
you
killed to fight.
Is Is that the same word? Is that the
same word? You said it means No. Is that
the same word? Is that what you said? Is
that the same word? No, because you're
Thank you. So, is that the Is that the
same word here? What are you proving? Is
that the same word here? Is that the
same word? When we say killed, it is the
same. Is this the same word that you put
in here? Yes, it's right. Look, look.
Look at the letters here. Look at the
letters. That's katal katala. It's a
It's not a See, I know Arabic. It's a Is
it katala
[Music]
or you put that in and this is it? No,
there's no dumma. No dhamma. I This is
Google translate. It's not going to do
that. It's not going to It's not going
to show you the dumb. What do you want
from me, bro? What do you want me to do?
I'm trying to I'm trying to help you
understand that it's not a dialect
issue.
Literally, means to fight. Is to kill.
Be killed. Be killed. In Arabic, it
gives
me that completely different. Do you do
you take Do you take when are you Sunni?
I'm Sunni. Yes. Then you have to take as
a kid. Yes. Okay. Do you know who Tabari
is? No. Okay. Alabari is one of the
greatest taps scholars. Alabari. Alabari
shows you even says he acknowledges the
difference. One is to fight, one is to
be killed. And he says that this one
right here, coutila doesn't make any
sense because the verse follows up by
saying and they did not give up and you
know they didn't lose hope. They have to
be alive in order to not give up and not
lose hope. So he argues that this one is
more correct than coutila. Katala is
more correct than coutila. Okay. Okay.
So the scholars acknowledge there's a
difference in the meaning. It's not just
I work with you. Okay. What's the point
here? The point is is that they're not
the same. They're not the same. Okay. I
already explained to you and to tell
them why this is wrong through Google
Translate through my I told you this is
a dialect issue. So I will go along with
you just like you went along with me in
the beginning. I'll go along with you.
You're telling me that this little
difference which is not true. This
little difference
makes it disvalidates the entire Quran.
it. No, what it does is it invalidates
the claim that you guys make about the
Quran. You guys claim, look, this is the
claim. The claim is there's only one
Quran unchanged word for word, letter
for letter, the same. That's the claim.
So, all I got to do is show you two
Qurans that have different words. And
then all I have to claim is I'm going to
repeat is tell you that bro, this is a
dialect thing. Let's let's give you
which I I already I let you said, okay,
whatever. Even if this does not
invalidate anything about Islam or
promote Christianity, I don't know what
you're trying to do here. I just told
you. And it seems like you guys set up
here every now and then. If if if
there's two Qurans that have different
words, is there only one Quran?
There is only one Quran. Absolutely.
They're not different words. They're not
different words. Again, it's the same
[__] word. I put it on Google
Translate. You could do the same. What
What makes What makes Islam true to you?
Uh well, the fact again Quran has never
been changed. I just showed you that. So
that's You didn't show me nothing, bro.
So which one of these are correct? The
same words. Which one of these? They are
both correct. But are they the same?
They're both correct. They meant the
same thing. Exactly. A change in dialect
is not a change in language. It's not
dialect. It's the word difference. What
is dialect? What is dialect? That's why
when I put That's why when I put killed
in dialect and I put to fight as you
say, what is what is a completely
different thing? What is what is
dialect? Listen, different ways of
pronunciation. And there you go.
different ways of pronouncing words. The
word's going to stay the same. The word
and it has Okay. But if one is katala
versus kila pronunciation, those are not
the same word. It is. It's
pronunciation. It means the same thing.
It's pronounced different. Okay. What?
Okay, bro. It means the same things
different. I I got you on translate. You
got it. I put your translation into tu
and I got a completely different word.
It's obviously different. Okay.
It's all right, man. It's all right. I
got all the answers, bro. It's cool.
It's all right. And this is what
happens, man. The the the desperateness
of Islam, bro. The desperateness of
Islam. They're all the same. Same words,
same letter, same thing. That's the
claim. He acknowledges is that there's a
difference in one breath. And then says,
"Well, even if there's a difference,
this doesn't disprove Islam." Okay. No,
but it disproves your claim that there's
only one Quran, right? Well, no, they're
the same Quran. It's only one Quran.
Yeah. Get out. Take care of yourself,
man. Watch your head on the way out,
dog.
Oh my god.
[Music]